foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on
[Music]
an angel or a Dean but not quite human
either
who are you
your memories
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
why don't you look after him for me
what Me by myself
learn to fight for others not just for
yourself
I'm sure he'll give you lots of practice
please wait if we can get to the alpha
verse and stop Singularity we might be
able to help him you have to be the one
to find all the chaos gears look I know
how you feel so
trust me he means a lot to me too
[Music]
I literally have bigger fish to fry
[Music]
getting away batty
so close the anticipation is killing me
fear not now is the time to charge
forward
[Music]
shall we I'll leave the driving to you
of course
the Full Throttle it is then doctor
I'll never bow to anyone again not even
myself
then we'd better be off
[Music]
I think you have me mistaken for someone
else oh that a simple ball swirl just
wait until I get really chatty
singularity
[Music]
and end all of this destruction
psycho
better be okay
[Music]
it seems the hotline has been
disconnected
myself
[Music]